una decisión difícil este sábado el
alcalde de río de janeiro anunció que se
cancelará las fiestas de fin de año en
la ciudad brasileña debido a la
presencia en el país de la variante del
estrés co2 omicron respetamos la ciencia
como se trata de opiniones divergentes
entre los comités científicos nos
quedaremos siempre con la más
restrictiva el comité el ayuntamiento
dice que si el comité estatal dice que
no así que no se puede cancelar hemos
entonces la celebración oficial del año
nuevo en río aunque la temporada de
navidad era esperada por muchos después
de dos años de restricciones los
habitantes de la ciudad maravillosa
acogen esta novedad con un poco de
excepción pero entienden la restricción
sanitaria al se hace más noche está muy
triste percibir esta noticia es muy
triste es un buen día para ganar dinero
llevamos dos años de pandemia y un año
sin fiestas de año nuevo pero es por la
salud de la gente
hay muchas personas reunidas en la playa
más de 3 millones de personas que viven
de fiesta y no hay manera de controlar
si se han vacunado quién lo ha hecho y
quién no desgraciadamente es una medida
que hay que tomar pensando en el bien
colectivo
de momento brasil cuenta con seis casos
confirmados de personas infectadas por
un micrón 27 otras capitales tomaron
medidas similares a la del río esas
nuevas restricciones despiertan el temor
de que también se suspende por el
segundo año consecutivo el tradicional
carnaval programado para finales de
febrero podría ser más difícil de
aceptar que la cancelación de las
celebraciones de fin de año